[Music]
hello guys today's Grand Master's choice
lecture and today's topic will be a how
to attack in real oppas martial attack
and I'll actually flip the board because
we are mostly interested right now from
blacks perspective how to because we
want to attack with black pieces so I'm
going to show one actually my only game
if I remember correctly martial attack
itself because people always play
usually not always but usually were
running away with some anti martial
stuff but in this game the only game I
got to play the main martial attack with
black pieces and I managed to win a very
nice game by creating powerful attack so
I follow I would bring bring it to this
lecture and because there is lot there
are many positions to talk about there
were lots of interesting things going on
and lots of it was my preparation back
in the day so I feel like it's
definitely worth it to show this game so
let's just start it so e45 and then the
396 the game is against bugged an
international master but right now
already grown master David Peruvian
Russian Grandmaster B should be v eh6
Bishop a4 9 F 6 short Castle shall be 7
rook e1 v 5 we should be free short
castle and if the six obviously there is
no any more marginal Titus why it's
important place or castle first
and right now my open plate c3 allowing
the marshal in my other games
in 2000 and Plato also sam-7 disposition
he played against me a4 and after
something came after some fight it was
eventually a drop I played before here
and was a drawing this game however here
c3 happened in d5 it takes d5 Knight
takes d5 and of course defies the
marshal attack is why this is quite
important move order not to play d6 but
short castle not 25 in one move
basically so d5 it takes d5 Knight takes
d5 Knight takes e5 @ x t5 worked exit 5
C 6 and right now this is the first
position where White has some choice
basically there are 2 moves may be free
but like after all technically in
royalty 2 moves because White has to
decide well played t3 or t4 and there's
also of course even at first but
eventually then still there is either d3
or d4 so basically there is no way
around it so old theory goes like d4
Bishop d6 rook e1 and Queen h4 g3 queen
is free
this is the let's say old theory that
has been played here like you know long
long time ago I show myself when but
like it used to be the most popular
approach here for white and the line
goes like Bishop e3 Bishop g4 or
something these days 92 and Queen h5 I'm
not mistaken is the move and basically
black has a good conversation at least
theories constitute considering that
black has a good conversation for the
sacrifice pawn and a pretty magic rivet
and the thing is the trend has shifted
towards here move d3 and did I mean to
ask ourselves why because the thing is
after d4 Bishop d6 rogue one Queen h4 g3
Queen h3 right now if that's the main
move of course visually free
however if rook F 4 with idea rubies
form expert
as well right now black can play move g5
and that's the key idea that in martial
attack that black has that if Bishop if
what goes d4 and this rookie for line
there is this g5 stopping group h4 right
now and Bishop g5 is impossible because
of Queen f5 and there is double attack
on rook and the bishop and because of
this and if what doesn't take on three v
g5 actually is helping black you know to
gain space on the Queen side so
important squares and Bishop a5 comes
into play attacking the rook and while
Luke has to go back so basically what is
a little wasting precious stamp is here
which could be important later in the
later phase of the game so that's the
reason why they stopped playing de frida
for by instead playing they start
playing d3 and the ideas after Bishop d6
rook e1 and right now if Queen h4
Blackwood why would play with g3 Queen
h3 and rookie form now and the thing is
that if g5 we should take g5 a rook is
pretty much protected on e4 and after 25
there pitchin can simply retreat almost
anywhere let's say even here and the
pawn is protecting the rock and that's
the big difference and that's the reason
why Blues are playing d3 main reason and
and if of course there have been
recently few games and most notably I
don't remember how they came went to die
versus Geary and I need Akira made made
a draw like it was quite comfortable I
feel quite comfortably I think he play
Knight f6 rotate for Queen f5 something
like this maybe h6 first I don't
remember exactly this game but this is
of less importance because create for is
by far not the most popular move right
now because this would be for us
consider cyber for white therefore the
theory developed Bishop f5 and Bishop a5
is correct move the best according to
the theory and we right now we need to
ask one is to ask ourselves
what to do next and the thing is that
white needs to do somehow those pieces
Bishop on c1 item b1 that's why they're
highlighted as well so in here the main
move of course this one well my oppinion
plate right now is Queen f3 if that's a
92 black can there have been some games
like this and there it is of course 94
and the main point of this move is that
if Knight Bishop takes d3 there could be
some problem with 94 and white there's
not anything better than this this and
right now White has pair of bishops
which could be which could give some
edge and edge to white however in this
position what black can play simply
Knight f4 which is much stronger after
94 there is tactical idea Knight XD 3
and with this maneuver black is at least
fine and what should be a little bit
even a little bit careful not to get
worse but like because the rough right
now White's under pressure but of course
with core place is just equal but that's
the reason why 92 is not so great
instead Queen f3 Canaries the pie for
the main move and of course right now
why black is again big choice theory
modern theory in this position is pretty
much very extensive there is Queen h4
move which I played in this game there
is but there also there is also Mookie a
which is extremely complicated
Bishop g6 I feel like the gay first game
Bishop d6 was Anand vs. Mongoose Carlsen
in 2014 maybe maybe 15 I don't remember
exactly and also Queen f6 all of them
are very very possible and they're just
different they're just different
I decided to go for the most popular one
which is Queen h4 and right now White
has to deal with Quinta h2 somehow and
g3 is by far the main choice by the fury
of course it attacks the quiz game game
gives additional Tempe to White Queen h3
and right now
this Bishop on v3 is a little bit I'm is
well-placed but like I have to put it
it's very well researched by the i-95
and white the right now can take this
pawn right it seems like what I can take
this pawn but this Bishop will be much
better place if this could somehow we
move on g2 so it's well placed on be
free but still a little bit misplaced if
it could be on g2 while we simply better
and because the king would be very safe
on g1 but this business won't be free
and this is a little bit of a problem
and the vol squares around white kink
and our make way working a little bit
vulnerable in some lines and that's sort
of where white looks for counter play
it's typical for martial of course
because we shall be free it's always
there and black tries to expand on the
kingside and of course we want one of
the main fury compositions and in the
game have a mission takes d5 in order to
quickly cover the alternatives which are
two main moves right now our Bishop III
which is the most popular move and the
little bit less mother mu is 92 I'll
start with 92 after Knight d2 there have
been lately game Dingley rain versus red
job of and time where job of and sorry
it was a time with Roger versus ding
Durant I flipped the colors and the game
happened rocky 8 right efore Bishop g4
Queen g2 and right now
Queen h5 could be possible but the most
precise way to full equality for black
here is just to trade queens and play a
5 there is the spin on the e-file that
will block this kind of unpleasant
white played place normally here g3
Bishop h5 and Bishop f4 other trying to
create some I know to attack the bishop
and develop the pieces will protect the
only one as well the thing is right now
that black count is
take on e4 because of this pin on this
diagonal so if anytime white takes this
one black text before F takes e4 d takes
e4 we are pinned and therefore black has
to use very specific tactical operation
in order to maintain the equality and
the way to do it is by taking and right
now very powerful move Bishop F sorry
not here and right now very powerful
move Bishop f3 and the idea behind this
move is to lower the King to the f3
square and right now take it the f4 pawn
with the rook King Joffrey and roof to
Rock Tennessee 4 and this this is one of
the end games in Marshall this quite
extensively analyzed and really lady
they've been game there has been game as
I said right above versus King Lear and
and but but engineers consider this and
game has an equal and game and almost
all the games as far as I know have an
in know in drawers so it doesn't bring
much this line in general of course what
can look for some ideas but in general
blog is doing well so this is 92 in this
position a second move is we should be
free which is the most popular one right
now Bishop takes D free night 92 and
right now there are two moves for for
black either Queen f5 which is the most
popular one and it's like there been
many many games like this or with a bit
less less popular but lately gaining
more and more popularity Bishop f5 both
moves are pretty much relating to good
position for for black the question is
you know whether what blasts player
would playing with black is you know
feel like doing more so queen of five
let's say be shot before and right now
both rook Fe Heydrich FD 8 is possible
basically what tries to give back that
the extra pointed that white has
initially here but try to draw the
pieces as I was saying earlier this
problem was pieces when I efficiency 192
to be developed somehow and by Bishop
III by Bishop takes D 392 wide once took
place this night only four and try to
hoping to get pair of Bishops maybe
challenge the quiz I a four as well so
here we know fides was a theory I want
to quickly show maybe Bishop a5 because
it's less common and such grandmasters
lately like Nikita with you go over gain
Tomashevsky Gabrielle sarkeesian or said
to Rahman from India Grandmaster also
played so it's gains popularity here and
probably for a reason so let's have a
look visualize device takes d5 Queen
takes d5 rook FD 8 and this is one of
the main lines Queen g2 and I feel like
after quit XG 2 King text g2 before this
typical Marshall like in the game where
black is pawn down but a pair of bishops
offers full compensation for the
material deficit that's what I believe
maybe people who go with me for this
line with white pieces disagree but I
feel like white has I mean black has
decent compensation so if Bishop before
I think this was Saran a versus
Outremont game and right now I found a
little small improvement we shop f8 if
I'm not mistaken
yeah I feel like Bishop f8 is just
improvement over that game and right now
black wants to play a 5 a 4 Bishop e6
maybe look a c8 there is certain
pressure on the Queen side that black
heads and I feel like there is more
enough I mean not more enough but like
enough conversation took me 10 full
equality without any serious problems so
my opponent decided in this position
decided to play Bishop takes d5 which is
sort of a very greedy move after its
tasty 5 Queen to 85
of course if let's say Bishop e3 happens
and I will just take on d3 and the same
if 92 red taking this pawn but
giving the pawn back it's the sort of
similar to what we discussed after
Bishop III not immunity but with include
Bishop takes d5 and I don't think it
makes any difference I feel like plug is
doing very well after both right now
Queen a5 or maybe should be Phi 1
transpose the same position as earlier
pretty much black is black is doing well
so it makes it not much sense and so my
opponent played very greedy move Queen
takes d5 and this approach has been
tested in practice already several times
but in that a time of being played in
2017 it was not quite popular and it I
think if the most popular very popular
in 90s and early 2000s but in 2017 when
I played this game it wasn't popular I
don't think this has been popular
approached by white even even even
nowadays so as I said here visually 392
is the most popular one nowadays visual
takes d5 is a very greedy approach and
but also quite risky like black white
takes up some risk is of course very
challenging because there are two extra
pounds but in general I feel like black
should have good compensation for for
the sacrifice material here so I play
rook 88 the very natural move Queen G 2
and right now this is the first critical
position which in which black is
essentially two possibilities first
possibility is to simply play Queen
takes G to King takes G to and mission
takes D 3 and we get very similar and
get away which one to what the one we
just discussed and of course black
should be doing quite well because
Bishop e3 92
if white coat visual 392 black can
always go for before try to challenge
the Queen side and there should be more
than I mean like should be enough
conversation to all the equality however
this is certainly possible but however
there is also a different approach
second approach is the one I chose we
just Queen
five and queen h5 has completely
different strategy than Quinta eg2
Bishop d3 itself playing for equality
hoping to equalize or like you know to
hold the bands in the bone down and game
thanks to the pair of Bishops black
right now tries to build an attack on
the Kings side because the white
sacrifice sorry traded the light square
bishop
all those squares around black king are
very weak and having this Bishop on f5
we can try to exploit that by playing
Bishop h3 maybe Bishop g4 Bishop fue if
we if we can and also we can if if
possible we can also consider taking
this pawn if because it's still hanging
and then try to create an attack by at
first reducing the material deficit that
we have right now
so this Queen each five is very
interesting approach that I thought that
it's worth testing and of course of
course to my analysis and I feel like
this is a very good move and attempt for
black to play for the initiative and
play for a win here and it's after Queen
the2 playing for the equality right now
while also has to be really careful not
to go wrong and not to make a mistake
because it could get really really out
of hand because of this very exposed
King on g1 so my apparently should be
free a play Bishop h3 obviously I could
have also taken spondee free but Knight
d2 and I would have to if I wanted to go
back to let's say f5h three let's say
you know it's possible but it's not the
idea of thing because I always already
one-time fee just to get one pawn and I
felt that it makes no sense to just to
collect one pawn and to waste precious
Tempe actually to leave into 10-piece
because we have to take go back and play
Bishop h3 makes sort of no sense to do
it while I can do it at once with Bishop
h3 right now and asking merely serious
questions to the white queen which is
free a cover-up on
- so right now my opponent play Queen
each one trying to hold on all the light
squares and right now basically it's
time to would like to launch the attack
and I played right now move f5 f5 with
the idea obviously f4 and in bringing
all the pieces to the game I would like
to make a small note even though black
is two pawns down all the pieces are
part of our party's been in the game
while white pieces especially now those
two are not there yet and if they are
not there yet and I've already written a
four it means in general in general mean
that white has the black has good
compensation for the sacrifice material
because it does if this night was
already on d2 they're saying you might
use renergie but no because for balance
were already here white could come here
playing some of the Queen afraid try to
you know kick this Queen out free
probably for where is Bishop it's as
great as on h3 you know groups are
connected always a backdoor no any back
rank issues you know it's just extra
Tempe and possibly the moves like a four
could be considered right now because
you know just stopping a for and try to
hold on the direct squares but the thing
is black and white is not in time to do
any of this so for instance if Knight d2
already a4 is very strong like basically
opening the king side and probably
buggies just nearly winning here so if
if first question we to ask ourselves
would have to what happens after f4
after f4 black has very powerful move
Bishop c7 and right now we've written
rook takes D free so if so let's save 92
we just simply take route 83 and is this
exactly same position like earlier for
instance a few moves earlier like after
let's say here let's say we should be
free I played right now Bishop h3 but if
I could play this I could have played
this and the nine
- so this is very similar to this
position in the following one but with a
big difference that they're already
pawns on a 5 and a 4 already there and
did significantly weakens the White King
because of the diagonal is open right
now because bone is already on f4 so
white can blacken cause you're playing
group tech is afraid somebody should be
6 so it is definitely in blacks favor
that f5f5f5 moves are included so it is
not so great a 92 and if d4 trying to
protect this pawn temple in 92
suddenly black can continue the attack
by playing simply g5 and again both
pieces night on b1 openly what are not
joining the game they're not
participating in the game and if F takes
G v g5 f4 is just crushing attack there
is like it's just much faster here with
King side play so my apparently here
Bishop b6 which is a very good move
and the idea Bishop d6 to gain some time
in essential tempest while dealing with
my attack so I can't because for now I
have to move the rook somewhere I can't
just let it be there and hope that my
attack will kind of you know will be
going on I still need manpower for the
attack to be successful so I need to
preserve this rook somehow and the
question is where to go the rook and I
play group d7 and the roof d7 is one of
the mapping in two possible moves the
second possible move here is root b8 and
I knew about both of them back in the
day when I was playing this game however
if I have to if I have I had this
position here once again I probably
would have played room p8 because it
leads to more how to put it more
fighting position if it's of course in
this move is a novelty to the best of my
knowledge and it creates better chances
for for black to let's say more like
crazy better chances
or kind of like chances more chances for
Y to go wrong than the rope d7 because
if room d7 helped me already played like
a few times and claimed my game so
probably if I placed 457 again people
would like to know what to do then
madruga is extremely interesting
alternative that creates some practical
problems for for white so if let's say
if 25 King h8 let's say Bishop d4 make
sense so centralize this Bishop of
course black-white kind of take Queen
takes this is because Queen f3 and this
is simply check my queen g2 next right
so white lady should before and after we
shot before we can play either rook BD 8
or FD 8 both moves are pretty much
possible and I'm not sure which ones
better or everything is very interesting
right now and but the thing is that in
general black tries to black hit
everywhere big conversation of course
right now Queen has to move somewhere
because discover discovery attack on the
Queen Bishop takes g3 for instance is is
a big threat so for instance Queen's
things would be c8 again chasing the
Queen Queen b7 Roxy 7 Queen h1 and right
now there are many moves I thought that
interesting one could be Queen g5 is one
of the possible moves not the only one
but very interesting one the ideas was
to stop 92 it decide it was peas aren't
coming to the game
why black will definitely have some
compensation here and this is one of the
ways to maintain initiative on a black
side right now and the bodies are not
easily getting to the game now they free
also of course it's possible but the
question is what would next is not only
free 92 doesn't really belong there well
if what boy could bring this night to a
friend only 5 the other would be over
but only if we doesn't still do much so
I feel like black has a pretty good
conversation here
so Ruby it is a very good alternative to
the word I played right now
seven which is also but Robeson of
course it's also very good move so Quinn
d5 happened King age eight and right now
a 92 funniest bishop is coming to the
game and this is sort of a problem with
this Rudy seven line that you know he
attacks here which should be six my rock
and I just playroom discern defending it
there was a move root beer which put
some pressure on black on white so
that's why I feel like ruby is a little
bit more accurate however both moves are
pretty much possible the probably wrong
discern is that this day's did and right
now ninety two and this night is coming
to the game and right now of course
something like a big problem because it
was still my preparation I believe black
is doing well here but if I wanted to
kind of play for win
rubia was possibly a better pair like a
better choice you know at least for the
future games so after 92 right now the
fret big Fred right now is of course
moved like 93 95 and so on
maybe Queen a free as well to and to try
to rathe Queens and you know try to you
know stop blacks activity and if black
doesn't do anything some anything
critical or like very aggressive right
now blacks initiative will indeed
evaporate so therefore black simply has
to go for some sharp stuff and there is
no no sort of coming back after this
basically from now so in the spirit of
sort of Marshall attack Bishop HD free
we should say HD free it's a spy in
spirit of this gambit with HD free black
with black I'm basically decided to go
for this rogue sacrifice without extra
free quint xd7 only move otherwise what
else and right now very very powerful
move Bishop f4 and the idea is that
below tonight on d2 is hanging Queen put
the square on g2
is right now vulnerable because there is
no apology for anymore and if my queen
can get to either g5j 4 or g6 course
queen g2 will be basically made into
with like yeah basically will be made
into moves right so Bishop a4 is very
important move it's also essential not
to play Bishop days h2 because after
King days h2 there is no really follow
up to block the attack
it's also important not to sacrifice too
much because there we still in pieces to
conduct yet I would say Bishop g4 kim
jiwon no follow up really just came over
why this week so it would be a big
mistake
that's why Bishop before is very strong
move and until this moment I remember
that my open is playing quite fast
possibly was still part of his
preparation and I remember that it it's
this position back then was still
nothing what not a new one it was still
it still happened previously I don't
remember what year was this game but I
remember it was game I think I don't
remember who was playing with white but
with black was playing at in back row
and I think was the Anne Smith versus a
team back row I'm not that yeah that's
right yeah it was the N Smith versus a
team back row don't you remember what
year but there was Jan Smith versus at
him back row that's my what year but it
was in vikon's they're in this position
I know I knew that a team back row won
the game and position looks quite scary
for for white and in this position white
needs to basically ask question what to
do here I like Queen g5 the Queen comes
to g2 is a checkmate right so it's not
so easy to deal with it because only 2
is hanging so we need to decide sort of
how to what to do at some point like
here so therefore I thought about many
moves here but in general all of them
contain the same
yeah white needs to bring this queen to
the long diagonal and coverage it to
square otherwise it just made so there
are several moves the Queen t5 quiz
seasick Quimby Sonora opal or are all
possible but as a general rule of thumb
I would say the most precise way in
general interest is to place Queen in a
center meaning centralize the Queen
there for about 25 right now is the is
by far the best move this is not what
happened in the game however it could
could have easily happened and after we
shall taste it - I thought that 26 is
the again the most accurate move however
Queen in the game happened Queen c6
which after Bishop takes D to anyway is
the best move 26 would have led to
exactly the same position so let's
discuss this let's say Queen d5 let's
say because Queen and now Queen d6 so
this is the main position of the of the
line could happen either after
coincidence Queen 26 or Queenie 526 this
this didn't happen the game but this was
the kind of critical for the entire line
and right now I I remember analyzed two
moves Ruby Ruby g8 and also look see it
actually move through Juke see it and
the Queen g5 of course Queen g5 also
makes a lot of sense just to give track
and the floral that could force the
White Queen to move back to g3
because that's the entire idea of 26 to
hit the road but also the offensive idea
of bringing the Queen to g3 to AG file
so let's discuss all those moves if rook
c8 I don't like this move to be honest
because we're gonna see it is a little
bit loose and my back rank is right now
it could be a problem in some lies so I
say what goes 25 with the fret idea of
Bishop before I'm not entirely convinced
what to do here with with white so and
for instance if let's say Bishop g4
trying to I don't know maybe Bishop a
free or Bishop a free maybe play queen
g4 then or something suddenly it could
be not so easy
because of did before which I ate and
right now a beautiful move h4 and
suddenly while blacks attack is is gone
and because after quit XH for Quinta
hundred seven is simply winning because
we ate made so as black we also need to
be careful here
Roxy a would be therefore I think an
inaccuracy the little bit bear move is
Queen g5 however after Queen G frequent
age six Bishop d4 again Bishop belongs
to d4 black white needs to create Condor
plate on g7 square in order to four to
distract you know blacks forces from you
know conducting the attack on the King
side so right now for Bishop takes one
rook takes one f4 is by far the best for
black but let's say Queen f3 and I
didn't see again kind of what to do here
with black that's a queen g6 King which
one makes is the only move and rather a
focus of this that makes a lot of sense
but and seemingly black is wing because
Bishop c6 right it's like if black can
get this Bishop this long diagonal it
seems like black is winning but there is
one I think only move Queen g2 and
suddenly there is no clear follow up
because rook Bishop C is just f3 and we
can't forget that everywhere in all
those lines what has extra pawn so if
white manages to trade Queens and sim
and simply play different color bishops
opposite color bishops with let's say
rooks on the board it is not a draw it's
still far from and draw and why
definitely has lots of winning chances
so ionize Hiroki a trying to you know
simplify the position and because it
would trade both Queens and rooks it
should certainly be a draw because of
the definite opposite color bishops so
Ruby g1 and right now I couldn't find
actually what to do here with with black
and I've thought that white is doing
quite well and yeah I thought would be
sound for instance some random computer
line but the thing is like what else
like we should seek just f3 does there's
no no problem here and
Bob because if they be 56 Y comes move
6f3 and right now if what can play Queen
f2 suddenly we are getting made on g7
right so it's not so easy and if we
trade Queens of course it is - sorry we
should 6f3
it's definitely right now - white favor
because even rookie - is just met by for
instance King itch-free
okay you three extra Queen King b7 I was
taking f1 and rook g7 next is coming
if we go back then King F - it's just
extra pawn it's not so easy here
I thought so ruby 7 I thought is the
best move but the right now Queen a8
Queenie 8 and again Queen e8 we should
be 8 and let's say h4 we get a similar
position were of opposite color bishops
but there are looks on the board and
positions definitely address still far
from my draw therefore quantifies bear
more than rook c8 but still not the best
so in this position
I thought still think that the best move
right now is Ruby g8 we need to preserve
our I mean save our preserve our rook
and keep it as close to the king as
possible in order to make sure that our
back rank is secured and analyzed Queen
g-free efforts the best move and right
now I I was thinking the bishop takes d1
which rotates one f4 and rook e8 in here
black has good chances to make a draw
and definitely there are some good
chances to make a draw however white
maintains you know two extra pounds but
the thing is that if we trade Queens
almost the opposite color Bishop endings
are very likely gonna end in a draw
because there's you know that's the
nature of the opposite color Bishop
endings if we most pawns will be very
likely blocked and
I feel like there's simply enough
conversation for black to to achieve a
draw here so this F level was the best
line for for black one important for for
why so one important thing to note if a
for seemingly the very natural move
kicking the Queen out of G free and
simply dropping the Queen but doesn't
really work and maybe this is what my
open miss because right now White has
rookie five wing forcing actually my
Queen out of H five if Queen each six
Queen f3 and white is winning and if H
the Quint xe5 then Quint xh3
and again white is wing because finally
what King is safe which took us to d4
and that simply came over just to show
Quint xe5 Queen takes h3 then we showed
before and this is simply came over so I
think that what was best for both sides
to do is basically go for this endgame a
for sacrificing this pawn but in order
to make sure too that force pieces will
be traded and there is no better move
than this and in this endgame very often
there is it is a draw because the
Queen's are very likely going to be
traded because either there is less safe
Bishop e3 let's say we can play h6 or
something like this or maybe even queen
g6 and yeah Quincy is the easiest and
dry right now
Queen g3 we already trade in the quiz it
should be a draw which if I also had
trained in the Queen's it should be a
draw and if Queen free again we can
trade the Queen's I'll play Queen g6
fires there are lots of ways they're
black can trade Queens here actually
Queenie free is a mistake right no
actually it's the same thing because
Queen frequency six Queen g3 is just a
draw because I mean would trade Queens
and should be should be we should save
this as black Queen b6 of course doesn't
work because Queen h3 so I feel like
this was the best attempt for before
white but still I believe that there
should be a draw however here we see six
happen in the game which one takes d2
and right now as I was saying Queen DC
was the best move but Marvin play Bishop
c5 and this most surprised me but
I knew that after Bishop c5 sorry bishop
yeah so I knew that after Queen d6 I
should play Luigi eight so after Bishop
c5 I thought that Queen o sistex is not
actually such a wonderful place and it
doesn't make any difference I could just
play Ruby Ruby Jade anyway so makes
perfect sense and right now
white needs to decide what to do next
and only my opponent was bearing the lot
of time and at some point he just went
down to basically playing on the
increment and he played right now 25 I
do remember exactly when he finally
started playing on increment but you
know it's just very difficult position
to play if you're caught off guard here
while I was still sort of in my prep so
my opponent play Queen d5 I don't really
see a big point of this move but
probably it's still quite okay
probably still quite okay however I feel
like Bishop d4 would be a little bit
more to the point we should be default
be a little more to the point because
put some pressure on g7 Queen still on
this long diagonal covers everything and
let's say covers especially G 2 square
is discovered so Queen g5 quantity to
another thing and if Bishop f4 there
could be some ideas connected with some
let's say maybe rookie 7 or something I
just trying to look for some counter
play on my king okay actually be certain
doesn't work because Queen g5 so
probably out late this move anyway
but there could be some move like for
instance if I'm thinking right now I
didn't check that to be honest too
deeply but there could be moved like
maybe Queen somewhere like Queen b7
something like this would be possible
maybe maybe maybe it could be possible
try to put some pressure on g7 also King
h1 could be possible right now I'm not
entirely sure I mean this could be
possible I think because if Bishop g4
I've if I'm not mistaken maybe I'm
missing something
actually I am missing a queen this is
just spinning so yeah this is actually
maybe already too late
this project of the bishop before is
still pretty much dangerous and if black
can somehow hold what can somehow hold
it I wouldn't be I mean with pure
miracle basically because it just looks
so dangerous black wants to play simply
Bishop g4 Bishop f3 and they clearly the
initiative on on black side right now
public play Queen d5 nothing easy
position to play so I right now played a
four and the idea is of course Bishop g4
Bishop f3 I don't I don't care about
this Bishop rook only one I care about
the attack so in order to keep attack
keep the attack we need to keep pieces
on the board and to do it is to play
Bishop f4 and threaten let's say maybe
at some point also visual takes h2 but
also Bishop g4 Bishop f3 put pressure on
h2 you know there's a saying the Freddie
stronger than its execution
meaning that you know it's better to
keep the threat still ongoing like so
possible in our hand today's h2 and
prepare Bishop a5 Bishop g4 first and
Bishop f3 because on issue is still Hank
y has to do something about it so the
game up in Ruby free and I feel like
this is already very bad position for
for what possibly it was still hold the
ball because after this if my visual
text if free it's still there were still
some chance but definitely positions
very dangerous after as a queen g4 King
H 1 F for Bishop d2 Queen e2
definitely it is black hos initiative
here what king is very exposed after
Bishop a4 queen of to let's say be
frequent xB to Ruby g1 quintic c3 for
instance
we should be 5-iron last Queen c8 and
White Castle compensation right now for
the for the pawn but right now it is
actually black with extra pawn and the
idea of bringing the Bishop from h3 to
the long diagonal - let's say c6 square
or d5 somehow it's very strong also
right now we need to make make make it
make a note about this fact that even if
we trade quiz right now with black
pieces and sometimes even rooks the this
endgame is also not to really draw there
are some traces for a draw but like if
we can block with the d5 pawn the D pawn
on d5 square there are certain chances
for for black to win this game as well
in the considering we trade above rooks
and queens
so definitely white it has to try to
defend this but it's not easy by far how
to how to do it so here F takes if we
happen in the game but F take C free has
this big sort of problem that right now
I have Queen e2 and after Queen e2
there is simply no almost no way to get
out of this I say almost because I'll
say because there is a wave which is
extremely complicated I'm sure it is the
moment but the thing is Queen e2 after
Queen e2 White King is simply in sort of
a cage and it cannot easily escape and
the thing is that if I can only bring my
rook to the to the attack on the Queen's
on the King side it'll be just simply
game over and but as long as my rubies
non-participating white is doing white
can hold because everything's covered
there is no immediate threats but if
only this group joins the attire let's
say for somehow g6 square ideally or
somewhere it just came over so but for
now we still can do it with white so my
opponent pretty right now Bishop before
and I played move here right now h6 and
right now I don't want to show the best
solution
for for black but I just really wanted
to show my approach to what I did in
this game because h6 is very very
natural move that I played and the idea
is to pay some the King h7 free the rook
from g8 Square and bring it to e6
because even let's say if black white
doesn't do anything let's say there is
move like a freaking h7 let's say Ruby
won or something that's a wrong yet
bouquet one rookie six the Queen can
never take because there's Quincy to
mate so this was my idea if I can bring
this rook somehow if only I can make
sure my king I'm not getting method on
the back rank and I'm not going back
method on the background after King h7
it simply game over so I played h6 a
Mapple and right now play move be free
and after this move is totally lost
because there is no know any defensive
idea here for for white and during the
game I also thought this simply it must
be winning but then I will during the
analysis with the engine stuff
I discovered amazing defensive idea that
white actually has it doesn't mean that
of course what is defend it was able to
fully define this position but
definitely what has good chances to
survive this relative relative to what
happen in the game so the best defense
is completely crazy defense is played
move before assuming there's no
difference between b3 and before right
so I just go to say go King h7 and but
right now white play simply let's say
move a4 and the idea is that Queen from
d5 is going to a2 and if this Queen
comes to a2 with it still covers the g2
Square and it is it does the the our
queen from Neto is simply kicked out of
there and I'm not saying this saves the
game but of course black is still much
better up very likely on the verge of
winning but this is
it was the best defense let's save I go
over say rook e8 or something like this
there's it's possible that white can
play Queen e2 and the right now after
Queen d3 bring the Queen to the king
side and or maybe this is one
possibility but also there is
possibility to play move that King F 2
and rubgy 1 try to sort of hold it like
this and of course it's far from a from
far from equality definitely Black has
huge many chances here but this was by
far the best defense and the most the
biggest resistance that white could you
know basically put here so but you know
it's just my own hero like I really had
like 30 seconds it was basically almost
impossible to come up with something
like this before I for Queen eight to
like it's just crazy so my plan played
be free and right now I played King h7
finally getting my getting out of the
back rank and making sure I'm not going
invited myself if I improve my rook
somehow because one more thing if I
please say play here rook e8 or
something let's say a three or something
Ruby six I can't do it because I'm
getting made it right so I can do it
therefore h6 is the very important idea
the freaking h7 and right now of course
I want to play rook e8 if I get to play
rook e8 next move rookie six is coming
in and that's you know game over because
the Queen can never take this rook if
it's only six so might want a very good
move Queen b7
but right now of course the field I
can't still play this because Queen d7
checkmate right but in order to win this
I need to bring this rook somehow and I
came up with a very interesting idea
here and this is actually very beautiful
I was very I still am proud of finding
this and the display King g6 King g6 and
actually I'm running out of with my king
to h5 square if I write my King 2h v
square this Queen g7 is not a problem
anymore if there is Queen f7 I can
simply play g6 Queen which 5 runs out of
all the checks let's say
I know whatever move let's say an a3 for
instance because there is nothing what
can do why I can never play efore
because Quincy - made Luke I never
actually joined the game because let's
say if it grew like you know a for let's
say desribe 421 mate or queen of one
mate there is why can't why ro kind of
leave the first rank and if this and
this Bishop actually has to defend every
pawn as well so the wife has to
basically wait so if let's say every
happens or whatever move back in place
simply Queen h4 king h5 Queen Esther is
made with simple g6 and Queen has to go
back to the d5 or b7 and we'll see what
happened in the game because they get
very similar thing happened 26 my
opponent took King h5 right now Quincy
six trying to get back to the to this
diagonal long diagonal and I played move
rook c8 trying to deflect White Queen
from this diagonal Queen b7 and right
now I played remove rook e8 and finally
I further ecigs booty six right if I if
my rook comes to Jesus just game over
and again I want to really say it again
if we're making on h5 o eiko I can do
whatever I want with my rook because
only 27 is just rookie six like I'm not
getting mad there is no check even and
if of course Queen f7 there is g6 and
this is what happened the game but I'll
so after King h5 my King is perfectly
say the sound and save on h5 White has
no any symbol single check and I finally
am able to bring my room to the attack
so my open play right now King Queen f7
I played move g6 simply covering from
the track and I think in database this
game ended but I remember because I
played this game in the game happened 25
and right now
I assure game with very nice move rookie
4 and cup finely
rook joins the attack covering the Queen
and honorable Queen g2 next movie
unavoidable so this is pretty much the
game this is the attack in the Marshall
Marshall
gambits attack that I wanted to to show
and I think it was a very instructive
game and one
of the nicest finish at least here that
I did I conducted a very mark up my
career so so was I think pretty much
more memorable gay for me and I was I'm
pretty happy about you know as moves
like h6 here can get some acoustic kh5
also hear all of those ideas would be
totally free and so on that we there is
like it's very very instructive and that
you know that by playing that there is
no time for anything else there is no
time for moves like oh no h6 or
something because then it was 93 95 days
will come and or whatever or maybe queen
of free and our initiative will
evaporate we that's why it's so
important when you attack just to play
the most sort of aggressive moves and
try to you know cause as much problems
for a pond as you can and what I did in
the game was pretty pretty happy about
it so finally I want to find to find a
major mistake here is Bishop c5 it still
doesn't lose but it makes White's task
extremely difficult Queen d6 is the best
try to sort of hope for you know a win
still for a while but with best play of
course black should be able to hold it
if Bishop c5 Ruby g8 White's position is
pretty much very dangerous however
possibly there still it's still not so
bad but after but you know in general
it's extremely difficult position to
play with white and this game I think
proved that you know over the board it
is very very dangerous and I've I still
really like blacks chances you know -
but I said by the many games black will
be able to win it a little human life
may become yours can hold it of course
but like on human level is extremely
scary so let's I find in this position
this is just you know really nice this
cuz Kings kind of caged right now in g1
if this join room by room joints and I'm
finally managed to do it the game was
over so this is pretty much all I have
for
this lecture about grandmasters choice
and yep so now I will start soon next
lecture so that's all I have for for
this about this marshalled I hope you
liked it and the next one will be about
games of the week which will be on
clutch games between Marcus Carson car
won thank you guys
[Music]
you